our hypothesis was that the sex
difference in depression is really a
strength difference not a sex difference
and so what we found is that when we
controlled for upper body strength the
sex difference in depression diminished
and actually went away in some of our
analyzes suggesting that once you
control for the differences in strength
between the Sexes there is no longer a
sex difference in depression and our our
hypothesis for that is that stronger
people are less likely to become
depressed and physically weaker people
are more likely to be depressed in our
data
one of the phenomenons that I'm most
interested in is depression how should
we understand depression through an
evolutionarily Adaptive lens
yeah well I think the if we look at
depression it's the most common mental
health problem and it is it is a problem
I don't nothing I say should be
construed as as trying to diminish the
fact that it is a very serious problem
but when we look at
the causes of depression it's very clear
the evidence is overwhelming that it's
adversity
um folks uh that experience adversity
are much higher risk of experiencing
depression
and folks with depression have been much
more likely to have experienced
adversity and there's quite a bit of
evidence that that's a causal
relationship that adversity causes
depression and rates were quite high in
comparison to something like
schizophrenia where the rates might be
around one percent
um rates of depression are at least 10
times higher than that if not more
so it's very common it's caused by
adversity and the symptoms unlike the
symptoms of schizophrenia which are kind
of odd including delusions and
hallucinations the depressions of the
symptoms of depression are things that
we've all experienced sadness loss of
Interest inability to sleep overeating
or lack of eating
um
anxious movements like this when we're
stressed out so their their symptoms are
are not
um strange or
um uncommon there are things that we've
all experienced in response to adversity
so I think these types of evidence
suggest that
um we should really think of depression
probably as an extreme form of sadness
or what Randy Thornhill and others have
called psychic pain and I think this is
the best fundamental approach an
evolutionary approach
to depression is thinking about physical
pain
it's unpleasant we don't like it it's
costly it prevents us from doing things
but we have special receptors for it and
special neural circuits for it and it is
caused by physical injuries
um and you might say why do we why do we
have to suffer physical pain well we
suffer it for a number of reasons one is
if you injure yourself
stop doing whatever you were doing to
injure yourself so it's a signal that
you're doing something that is going to
harm your biological Fitness as we call
it and so that's one clear function of
physical pain and the second clear
function is we begin to think about what
did I do to get myself into the
situation and and learn how do I avoid
this kind of situation in the future so
that physical pain you know when I broke
my ankle it hurt like hell but it kept
me off my feet it made me think don't do
that stupid thing that you did to break
your ankle uh and I've more or less
avoided breaking my ankle subsequently
and so Thornhill and others have
proposed
psychic pain is very analogous to that
um something bad is happening to you not
physically but socially perhaps
um your wife has left you your boyfriend
has left you you've lost your job
um that's bad for your biological
Fitness and you need to think about it
so you need to first of all stop doing
whatever it is that drove away your
romantic partner or got you fired or
causing your friends to disown you and
you need to think about that and you
really need to focus your attention
on that and then maybe learn uh don't do
whatever it was that you did that may
have caused your relationship to break
up or you'd get fired and it may turn
out that you didn't do anything wrong
but you need to think about it you need
to stop and say something really bad has
happened and I need to address this and
so psychic pain sadness and even
depression
um are probably very analogous to
psychic pain as a way to stop furthering
any problems that you have perhaps cause
or other people have caused you and and
maybe somebody else has has caused the
problem and you kind of need to deal
with them somehow so I think this this
is the uh sorry about that my cat cat
down there
um
uh we all need attention right
um so
uh and this this work was uh there's
many people that have kind of put
forward this idea Randy Thornhill
um Randy Nessie Paul Andrews is somebody
that's been currently working on this so
I think this is is the kind of the
the most likely uh evolutionary
explanation for
why would being depressed cause us to
act in the way that we do the symptoms
of depression like low energy like not
wanting to get out of bed and go and do
things like sometimes being anti-social
you know if I was to design a coping
mechanism for psychological pain some of
the time if I went through something in
the past that happened with my
relationship or with my friends I might
want to reach out to them more I want to
go out there and try and do things to
fix it but it seems like depression
causes people to be less Mobile in that
regard
yeah and um you might even bring up the
most mysterious symptom which is
suicidality why if something bad has
happened uh would you ever want to kill
yourself uh that's a horrible way to
increase your biological Fitness so
not all adversity is going to cause
depression so in many cases we do know
how to deal with adversity we do know
what to do and just for a second tell me
give me give me the um the definition of
adversity like what do you mean when you
say adversity
so from an evolutionary perspective it
would be any situation or circumstance
that's likely to decrease your
biological Fitness I.E decrease your
ability to survive and reproduce so
losing a mate is obviously horrible for
your reproduction
um getting sick or physical injury can
often trigger
um depression so that is obviously
something that is bad for your
biological Fitness getting fired that's
your source of resources that's what you
need to survive
so anything that would have a really
dramatic negative impact on your ability
to survive and reproduce is what I'm
referring to as adversity and you know
natural disasters
um things that are going to basically
reduce your access to resources and
mates and social partners
and all the kinds of things that we
needed to have access to on a daily
basis over evolutionary history so
that's what I mean by adversity and
we've all or death of a loved one that's
one of the most common ones and
um if your parent dies or your spouse
dies or a child dies that can be really
bad for your biological Fitness because
we really require our social Partners to
and we always did to survive and
reproduce we needed hunting partners and
mates and folks to share food with us
and take care of us when we're sick so
if one of those folks dies that's really
horrible potentially for your own
biological Fitness so that's what I mean
by adversity
and
um
what Paul Andrews argues I think quite
correctly is when something like that
happens you really need to shift your
cognitive resources to begin to think
about these problems because they're not
easy to solve
um if a mate leaves you
uh what do you do or if someone dies you
can't bring them back to life so these
kinds of problems this is where we think
depression is going to really kick in is
when you suffer adversity where the
solution isn't obvious
um you know what what you need to do to
address that kind of adversity isn't
clear and you're gonna it really takes a
lot of thinking so you're going to shift
your attention
to the problem and it's going to take a
lot of thinking to figure out what you
need to do and when you're doing that
you can't be doing something else so
there's a trade-off and that may just
require you taking a lot of time to
yourself to really think through these
things and the the strongest piece of
evidence for that is that rumination
intense rumination is a really major
component of depression for for many
people not all but it's a very common
component of depression that when people
get depressed they really start thinking
over and over and over about what
happened why did you know so-and-so
leave me or
did that and I'll just give you a
personal example when my dad died
he died of cancer and my mom became
depressed and she was really withdrawn
and what she was thinking about is could
she have
noticed something sooner and gotten him
to the doctor sooner could she have
noticed uh you know that something was
wrong
and um
you might say well he's dead what what
what could that help and it's not going
to help obviously bring back her husband
but it could help her when she's now
interacting with other family members to
really pay closer attention to things
that might be indicating some health
problem and so all that rumination about
my dad's cancer and the months leading
up to it before it was diagnosed
obviously wouldn't bring him back but
could have helped her
um potentially notice problems other
health problems in folks before they
become untreatable and in fact because
my dad died of colon cancer that's
highly heritable
she just started pestering me uh to go
get checked out and get a colonoscopy
which is of course the last thing
anybody wants to do and so after months
and months and months of pestering I
finally did it
and guess what they found a huge polyp
so uh maybe she saved my life by
thinking by becoming depressed and
really thinking carefully about what
happened to my Dad wow so that would be
an example that is how this might work
yeah oh my God so okay I I really like
uh peeling apart a phenomenon that
everybody that's listening to this will
be familiar with you know low mood then
getting across into depression some
people maybe even that have dealt with
suicidal ideations and stuff like that
and actually looking at them from
through a lens of okay why did this come
about because
especially if you are dealing with
severe low mood even more if it's
chronic if it's over an extended period
of time it feels like a personal curse
it feels like some
evil God from on high has decided to hit
you with an arrow but it wasn't Cupid's
arrow it was this depression arrow and
it's just the The Perfect Storm of your
thought loops poking you in exactly the
place that it's going to hurt you and it
feels so curated It Feels So
individualized for you and I think that
looking at it through this lens
hopefully kind of helps to just you know
relieve a little bit of that sense of
it's about me well it seems like it's
not about you it's about the
evolutionary pressures that would have
made these kinds of emotions useful
ancestrally and that story
of you with your dad and and your mum is
you know like it couldn't be more
perfect of an example
yeah
um and it again depression is really
adversive
um it's just like physical pain nobody
uh you know if you break your ankle
you'll know that um you won't be able to
sleep
um
you won't be able to do all kinds of
things that you could normally do so you
know and psychic pain is is very
analogous
um to that now I want to bring up a
second possible function of these kinds
of symptoms I think the ones that I
mentioned are probably the the primary
ones that hold across most if not all
cases of depression
but just like when we suffer a physical
injury
um it hurts that's our own personal
experience of it but in many cases we're
going to signal if we're a young kid
we're going to cry we may yell out we're
going to be we're going to have
expressions of of physical pain on our
face
and those are likely signals and signals
of need because when you suffer a
physical injury
or health problem you often can't
deal with it yourself you need people to
help you if you break your ankle uh
you're not going to be able to feed
yourself you may not be able to do all
kinds of things that you could normally
do and you may need to signal
for help and we have all kinds of
evolved signals like tears and crying
and screaming
um to signal that and I think depression
also involves a component of signaling
so psychic pain just like physical pain
often we can't address adversity
completely by ourselves
um and so there's going to be facial
expressions and I think some of that
those physical manifestations of
depression where you're not doing
anything our social partners are going
to pick up on that
and um they're going to make inferences
about our state of mind that something's
wrong
and I think that's that's another
evolutionary reason why depression does
involve some of these
um have some of these kinds of impacts
on our behavior that they are also to
Signal our social partners that we are
suffering adversity and we do need help
in in addressing some of these things so
that's probably a second reason for for
some of these symptoms is that signaling
component
why is there a sex difference in
depression why do men and women get it
at different rates and in differing
intensities
yeah we don't know
uh so this has been a huge area of
research it's a it's one of the biggest
sex differences out there women are
about twice as likely to be depressed as
men
and
um
there's been all kinds of is it
different rates of adversity are women
experiencing adversity at higher rates
than men are they somehow more
vulnerable
to a given level of adversity having
these emotions trigger and there's some
support for all these ideas
one idea one factor that we highlight
that I think is really is very well
established empirically
um but it's it's not really part of the
the
National conversation about depression
and that is that depression is really
intertwined with social conflict
um
that there's a lot of anger involved
typically and you think about it if
you're you know partner leaves you uh
you're going to be sad but you may also
be angry and of course that person is
leaving you probably because there's
some conflict between you in your
relationship
um
and or if you get fired from your job
again that suggests social conflict or
you're having some kind of family
situation
social conflict and so the evidence for
this is really overwhelming that social
conflict and anger are deeply
intertwined with depression in many many
cases and
so that's kind of our uh the angle of my
research group is taking on depression
is really looking at this aspect of
conflict because that's an area where
evolutionary thinking where evolutionary
theorists have pretty much spent ever
since star conflict and the struggle for
existence has been part of evolutionary
theory from the beginning and it's
really striking how important a theme
that is in depression so how might that
explain the sex difference
well one way that we all deal with
conflict often not just us humans but
across the animal kingdom is physical
aggression
um
and so when there's a conflict between
males there's physical aggression or
male female intersexual conflict often
involves male coercion
so the way that many many animals
including humans deal with conflict is
physical contests and in physical
contests
in animals and in humans individuals who
are physically stronger will often
Prevail in those conflicts
so our hypothesis was that males are
physically stronger than females um and
that's actually an extremely dramatic
sex difference there's almost no overlap
in upper body strength between males and
females almost all males are have
greater upper body strength than almost
all
females and that means in many many
conflicts
especially between men and women men are
going to Prevail due to that physical
advantage and that means that if you're
in a situation where you might be
experiencing depression if you can
Prevail due to your physical advantages
then you're not going to get depressed
and so what we did to test this idea is
we have a huge
nationally representative database of
upper body strength as well as
depression levels
and our hypothesis was that the sex
difference in depression is really a
strength difference not a sex difference
and so what we found is that when we
controlled for upper body strength
the sex difference in depression
diminished and actually went away in
some of our analyzes
suggesting that once you control for the
differences in strength between the
Sexes there is no longer a sex
difference in depression and our our
hypothesis for that is that stronger
people and that's exactly what we see
that stronger people are less likely to
become depressed and physically weaker
people are more likely to to be
depressed in our data
and that presumably tracks within the
Sexes as well that weaker men compared
to Stronger men have a greater
propensity to depression okay which
direction is the arrow of causation
going can I make myself less depressed
by becoming stronger
yeah we do
physical exercise uh does help with
depression but whether that is because
it's increasing
um some sense of an ability to deal with
adversity uh we don't know but you're
you're absolutely right those are the
right questions to ask always with these
correlational studies which ours is as
well what is the direction of causality
here or is there some third
confounding variable now in our study we
controlled for everything we could think
of to control for and we still see this
dramatic effect of strength on
um depression this negative association
despite controlling for all kinds of
things socioeconomic status age hormones
uh health status all kinds of things
um it looks like there's still this very
clear negative association between upper
body strength and depression but yeah
could you so you go to hit the gym and
and get rid of that depression I don't
know maybe
something that we should have yeah
I wonder what it is about strength what
was the measure of strength it used was
it hand grip
hand grip yeah
that's right yeah okay I wonder what it
is about
strength because that's not the only
measure of physical fitness you know
where persistence Hunters ancestrally
why is it not your VO2 max why is it not
your uh level of zone two uh Fitness or
your lactate threshold or some other uh
measure of Fitness because there are
multiple ways that you could measure
this right you know cardio why is it not
your flexibility your ability to get
into the box splits or
um whether you can do a good lunge
without getting into pain or something
like that
um presumably hand grip strength it's
it's not about the fact that the person
that can grip the stone or the piece of
wood the hardest has something it's that
that is an indicator Downstream for a
bunch of other things
so hand grip strength is a very good
index of upper body strength and upper
body strength is a very good index of
prevailing in physical fights
so we think given the clear evidence
that social conflicts are deeply
intertwined with depression
um and given the evidence that upper
body strength is
the one of the best predictors of
prevailing in physical aggression and
physical conflicts
that this is the key index so it's not
these other aspects of Health it's not a
health thing it's a it's a physical
fighting thing to resolve conflicts in
your interest
so that is so interesting MMA fighters
should be the least depressed people on
the planet by this yeah unless they got
unless they got beaten by somebody else
but yes yeah these guys uh we would
expect I mean that's what our data show
at least we don't we don't obviously
have in our data anyway
um
you know fight outcomes but we do it's
very clear that that the folks with the
greatest upper body strength are the
least likely
um to be depressed um and it's not
necessarily because they had to get in a
physical fight but they just when
there's a social conflict
um that Conflict at least our hypothesis
is and this is going to require a lot of
additional testing is that there are the
ones that are gonna
more often than not prevail
um and by prevailing that means that the
conflict resolved in their interests and
there's no need to get depressed things
worked out their way
does this get flipped on its head a
little bit when we talk about people who
commit suicide because I think I'm right
in saying that women
commit suicide or attempt suicide sorry
uh at a significantly higher rate than
men do but presumably one of the reasons
why men are able to be successful if
that's the right way to put it with
their suicide attempts is that they do
have this extra degree of lethality they
do have this extra amount of physical
strength which perhaps can mean they can
carry through with this what how do you
conceptualize the fact that women
attempt suicide more but men are commit
suicide more
yeah that's definitely true in the
United States it's true in a lot of
populations it's not true in every
population but it is a pretty where is
it not true
um I have to check to make sure I had my
stats right in this but um I think in
China we see really high rates of female
successful suicides
um but I'd want to double check that to
to be sure but I think that's one of the
the major exceptions with the little
asterisks that I have to go back and
look at my notes
um
and what most people think and what I
think seems really plausible is that men
are more likely to use lethal methods
like guns
um and that's one of the major reasons
why the suicide rate for man is much
higher than for women but you're right
the attempt rate for women is much
higher I think the key thing here
is that the attempt rate for both sexes
is dramatically higher than the success
rate so for men there's about 10 suicide
attempts per completion in let's say
young to middle aged adults in women it
may be especially in young women it may
be as high as 100 or more attempts per
completion so what we argue you're
kidding
is that really the phenomenon of
Interest here is the attempt not the
success and what we are arguing is that
um for the vast majority of suicidal
Behavior the the phenomenon of interest
is is the suicide attempt and that the
suicide the successful quote-unquote or
the suicide deaths
are the unintended accidental
consequences
of making an attempt that is serious but
hopefully won't actually succeed and our
argument here is similar to what I was
mentioning before that there's a
signaling component
to depression you need to Signal uh that
you're in need that you've suffered
adversity
but if there's conflict as I've
emphasized people may not believe you
um and so we all know situations where
for example women are experiencing
sexual harassment or sexual abuse and
they're not believed and the reason
they're not believed is there's conflict
um do they have some incentive to lie or
and that's of course what everybody
immediately will say on social media oh
she's just trying to manipulate the
situation so how do you convey and it's
a it's a kind of behavior that's often
private it's it's you know he said she
said how can you convince
other people
that you're telling the truth and again
this is where evolutionary theory comes
in there's a whole area of research
called credible signaling
um because uh in animals within species
and between species there's often
conflicts of interest between predators
and prey between males and females
between two males of the same species
and yet there's a big cost of actually
fighting or chasing down the prey so
there's all kinds of
signaling going on in non-human animals
and biologists for a long time have
wondered why are those signals honest
why should if there's a huge conflict of
interest between the signal sender and
the signal receiver why
should the receivers believe the sender
why aren't they just exaggerating
um their qualities if it's a mating
situation or their formidability if it's
a aggressive situation
and so there's a body of research on
ways that credible signals can evolve
and one of them is that the signals have
to have
um some cost or more accurately that the
the benefit of signaling has to outweigh
the costs for the sender
but the cost of the signal have to
outweigh the benefits for potential
cheaters so cheaters can't actually send
the signal because they can't afford to
do it and so what we're arguing is that
suicidality might be exactly one of
these honest signals of need and how it
would work
is uh if your life is going really well
you can't afford to actually do
something that puts your life at risk
um you can't take that one percent or
ten percent chance of killing yourself
um to get whatever benefit you might get
from social partners because your life
is already going really really well but
if your life is not going well if your
mate has just left you your potential
Fitness is really taking a huge hit and
in that case the benefits that you might
get from social partners by convincing
them that you genuinely are in need
might outweigh the cost of taking a one
percent chance of actually killing
yourself or a 10 chance of killing
yourself so we're arguing that
suicidality is a credible signal of need
in situations of adversity that can
convince skeptical social partners that
you're telling the truth that you really
do need their help
and what you hope is you'll you'll
engage in this kind of behavior where
you put yourself at real risk of
actually killing yourself but most of
the time you won't you'll survive and
then social Partners will believe yes
that person really does need my help and
you'll get the help you need but
unfortunately because the signal has to
have those it has to take a genuine risk
of death at the margins
so that in our view explains these these
tremendously High rates of
suicide attempts to completions uh in
both men and women
um
and then the sex difference in those
um maybe
because uh in our society
um
we have guns it's an extremely efficient
way
um to kill yourself unfortunately and
men are much more likely to use those
than than women maybe for cultural
reasons
how did natural selection create an
animal with the capacity to willfully
kill itself how is it that suicide
hasn't been selected out of the
population I don't understand how
something can be adaptive and and on top
of all of that suicide is moderately
heritable as well like what the [__]
does that mean yeah so let's think about
the case of a young woman who's
experiencing
um sexual harassment or sexual abuse
that's enormously costly to her
biological Fitness it's going to prevent
her
from you know may physically injure her
it may infect her with a serious disease
that could sterilize her it may get her
pregnant by some person who's not going
to invest in her so it's an enormous
enormous cost it's her Fitness and it
needs to stop but because of that
physical formidability difference that I
talked about she may not have the
ability
to stop her abuser by herself she needs
help and yet due to the
privacy of those kinds of behaviors he
said she said situation she may not get
that help people may be skeptical uh the
man's
um friends and family may back him up
and so what can she do she can't easily
physically resist him she's not getting
the social she may have married into his
family and be physically removed from
her own family uh in evolutionary
context or many traditional contexts
today so she just doesn't have the
social Partners in backup and yet She's
suffering a huge
it may be worth the one percent or even
ten percent chance of killing herself if
in the 90 to 90 percent
number of times that this kind of
behavior would happen she convinces
people that she's telling the truth and
that actually stops the abuse so it's
the potential benefits of convincing
social partners that you really do need
help that would outweigh the uh costs
that you might actually end up killing
yourself it's that benefit that explains
an RV at least in our Theory uh why
people are willing to take that extreme
kind of action
it's a it's a way to convince people
that you really don't need help
yes I understand
have you got any idea about whether
ancestrally men were more successful at
suicide attempts than women I'm
wondering whether
this is this signaling is is the same
ancestrally and we have a an
evolutionary mismatch between the tools
that men now have access to that means
that they can be more successful at
attempts I think that's a reasonable
hypothesis we have uh with my former
student and collaborator Kristen Sim
we've come through and Zach Garfield
we've come through the ethnographic
record on suicidal behaviors now these
are modern groups but modern groups many
of whom are living in ways that are
similar to the way we think were our
ancestors live traditional societies
hunter-gatherer societies and we've
scoured the ethnographic record for
every example of suicidal Behavior
and these records are not systematic so
they don't allow us to estimate rates of
lethal versus non-lethal uh Behavior or
anything like that
um what they do do is what we we do see
in in some of these societies that
almost all of the cases are female in
other cases almost all of the the cases
are male
um in others it's kind of a mix
so we can't
uh if men ancestrally
actually
took riskier kinds of you know engaged
in riskier kinds of suicidal behavior
that would have led to their deaths um
that's uh just something that I think we
can't see in the the ethnographic record
um but we do see all of the other things
that our Theory would predict we see
social conflict we see adversity
we see that if you survive you do get
help in most cases you do get social
benefits often somebody's being abused
by their parent and they
um attempt suicide and then the whole
village realizes and they they start
pressuring the family to treat this
person better
um or they engage in a suicide attempt
and they get their mate to return
somebody who had left them comes back
um or they get their husband to leave
leave his you know concubine or mistress
and come back to the family so it's all
the kinds of things that we see today
that trigger suicide attempts we see in
the epigraphic record and we also see
that these often if the person does
survive they do generate
benefits but yeah the sex difference is
not something we can
address with the data that we have
access to maybe somebody will more
clever than I am will figure out a way
to do it but I haven't figured out any
way to do it maybe by studying some of
the few
hunter-gatherer societies and
small-scale societies that exist today
if we study them more systematically for
suicidal behaviors we might be able to
begin to address that
question the problem is it's a it's an
incredibly stigmatized behavior and so
it's incredibly difficult to study this
and we have tried Kristin has made
several efforts to try and collect these
data and just the resistance of the
community to to actually talk about the
stuff is
um we haven't been able to overcome that
that challenge yet
one of the other things that I've been
considering sex difference is one of
them but age as well is another one what
can we learn from the onset of suicide
in relation to age
so what we see is that both depression
and suicide begin to really onset in
kind of middle adolescence to early
adulthood and that's when they really
pique the suicidal behaviors
um and then they gradually decline with
age we see the successful suicide rate
actually increasing with age but it's
always much much lower than the suicide
suicidal behaviorism until you get up to
about age 70 or so
um and what's striking to us is that
these behaviors are on setting
as people are transitioning from the
juvenile phase to the adult reproductive
phase of life and of course in the
juvenile phase typically most of us um
have protection from our family and our
parents
um we're not engaged in
inter or interests you know intra-sexual
mating competition we're not competing
for mates we're not competing for
resources
and when we see these behaviors on set
is right when we're transitioning from
that juvenile phase when we aren't
engaged in all these kinds of
competition to the adult reproductive
phase when intent competition can become
very very intense so meeting competition
resource competition so our hypothesis
for the onset of depression and
suicidality in adolescence is that this
is when individuals are transitioning to
um mating competition and resource
competition and they kind of peak in
early adulthood when that competition is
probably most intense and then it seems
to gradually decrease over the lifespan
um as mating competition uh is probably
decreasing as well
isn't the current highest risk group in
the US for suicide men aged 40 to 45 or
something like that I think white white
men are so the risk the risk the risk of
completions goes up with age
but the the risk the the frequency of
suicidal behaviors
is going down
um so you've got this kind of
suicidal behaviors really just spiking
incredibly in adolescents or an early
adulthood into your sort of mid-20s or
so
um an actual suicide deaths very very
low
and then the suicidal Behavior begins to
decrease as you go into middle age and
older age but the actual uh rates of
actual completions are going Are
Climbing but they're still well and
climbing but climbing presumably at a
rate if the number of attempts is lower
but the percentage of successes is
higher given the fact that we have I
think it's five times more men in middle
age
commit suicide successfully then girls
who are adolescents given the fact that
we have a mental health crisis around
young girls at the moment in the US
whatever it is 60 of teenage girls in
America say that they have persistent
feelings of hopelessness and doom or
something like that
um
they their ability to be successful in
this regard has to more than compensate
for the fact that you have significantly
lower numbers of attempts
that's right and so we don't have a
great explanation for that yet but what
we look and we look at just mortality
rates
uh from any kind of cause they kind of
follow the same kind of pattern
and so something about
um
so if you actually fit the curves
they're very very similar so it could it
be and we really don't know
um so is it the case that maybe older
individuals have to engage in costlier
signals to convince folks that they need
help for some reason so they're they're
engaging in riskier behaviors but also
as we get older we're more vulnerable to
dying from any kind of cause
and so it might be the case
um
it's kind of a combination of it of
engaging in in maybe costlier signals if
you will riskier kinds of behaviors uh
to actually get that signal across to
other people but also being uh more
physically vulnerable to uh having
something going wrong
um yeah
so so interesting is there a link
between suicide and intelligence
yeah so intelligence is not so I I look
at intelligence from um you know humans
compared to all other species uh and
we've obviously got these huge brains
but I don't really I've never really
looked at uh variation intelligence
within species so I can't say too much
it's not a variable that we have a very
good
um sort of the proxy for intelligence in
in most studies of evolution is is kind
of species level brain size
uh so if we look at you know us versus
chimps and other apes and other primates
and other mammals
um there's lots of good work in that
area but we when we're trying to think
about what does it mean for differences
intelligence within species
um it's not an area that I'm an expert
in but I haven't really seen any great
uh operationalization or evolutionary
rationale for uh within species
variation so I can't really answer your
question on that one unfortunately
one other uh kind of weird
to me at least phenomenon is postpartum
depression so women who have given birth
and then after that they have this onset
of depression have you looked at that
through an evolutionary lens can you
give some potential adaptive
explanations for that
yeah so that's actually was my
dissertation research and that's uh was
kind of an entry point into this whole
area
and from an evolutionary perspective on
the one hand postpartum depression is
really odd you've just
had reproductive success that that is
you know as we've learned from day one
is the whole uh how our whole physiology
and psychology is organized to reproduce
and so you've now successfully
reproduced you in most cases have a nice
healthy baby
um you are a mom and one of the richest
countries that has ever existed you have
more resources
um than anybody in the past could ever
imagine uh your baby is very likely you
know that the probability that it's
going to die from an infectious disease
is vanishingly small these days at least
a few are lucky enough to
live in a high income region
uh so what the heck is going on uh you
are feeling miserable you don't love
your baby
um
you may not be able to eat you may not
be able to care for your other children
it seems like just the most incredibly
paradoxical kind of experience you could
imagine
um
and so
what I started to do is look into what
are the circumstances
that seem to be associated with
postpartum depression
and the big one is lack of social
support lack of social support from your
husband lack of social support from your
family
and we know that
we humans are Cooperative breeders we
really you know takes a village we never
by ourselves we were always reproducing
in family units where husbands and
siblings and older children and
grandparents
um were helping us and we were hanging
out with the other moms and the other
parents and we were helping them take
care of their kids and they were helping
us take care of our kids
and if you didn't have that
uh there was no way that you were going
to be successful in raising that kid
ancestrally and what I found in the
evidence for this is overwhelming is
that many not all cases but many many
many cases of postpartum depression are
occurring in context where mothers feel
they don't have
social support often from the husband or
maybe from their other family members
and that would have been a cue
ancestrally
um that this child isn't gonna make it
and
um so what I've argued is it's exactly
this kind of adversity where we should
be experiencing psychic pain we should
really start thinking what is wrong why
am I not getting the social support I
need to help raise this kid
um and what can I do about it uh can I
get that social support somehow uh can I
juggle responsibilities
um and
um
if I can't
then I really should just stop caring
for this kid I uh and we know in um in
kinds of populations that approximate
our ancestral past
uh if you didn't have the resources
um
you might just not take care of that kid
to begin with and we often see very high
in fantaside rates in situations where
there is Extreme uh extremely limited
access
to resources but you shouldn't commit
and fantaside immediately uh you should
start signaling that you are genuinely
in need and you really can't raise this
kid in this in the circumstances the way
they are something's got to change and
so
I'm arguing that a lot of the
postpartum depression symptoms are a
form of psychic pain
you're not getting what you need and and
we also see it when the kid is unhealthy
if it's if there's pregnancy problems if
there's health problems in the child if
the mother has health problems
um these kinds of things are also
strongly Associated and probably causes
of postpartum depression and then you
should signal and you should use one of
these costly
signals that is going to convince people
that you're not just trying to
manipulate them and get more uh help
than you deserve that you really are in
need and you really do need extra help
or
you're going to stop taking care of this
kid and that kid is not just your kid
it's your husband's kid it's your
grandparents grandkids it's your
siblings niece or nephew and
biologically if you don't take care of
that kid it's going to have a negative
impact on their Fitness so they have an
incentive if you really are in need uh
to step in uh and help you get what you
need to to successfully raise the child
seeing
suicidality and depression through a
lens of signaling there's something
going on please give help uh having
especially suicide attempts be something
which is a very costly signal to try and
do it if you're just [__] about you
just want some attention but you don't
actually feel that bad is uh you're
flying pretty close to the wire I love
the idea of in older age it being a
combination of perhaps the signal needs
to be more reliable I.E more costly
which means that you fly closer to the
wire of mortality with your signal and
the fact that maybe your physiology is
just a little bit more fragile in some
way you're a little bit more vulnerable
to this I don't know if I would think
that a 45 year old man would be more
vulnerable than a 16 year old girl
um they both seem I don't know there's
some pretty robust 45 year old guys out
there I don't know that that's
interesting to me
um but I I just this conception is very
very uh
fascinating and I think hopefully should
help people to feel yeah a little bit
less sort of personally cursed
one of the other topics that I saw you
get into on Twitter recently was a
discussion about whether or not race
science is deeply embedded in
evolutionary psychology
where did this come from is it true that
race Sciences of foundational part of
evolutionary psychology is evolutionary
psychology racist
yeah I would argue it's it's probably
the least uh racist discipline
um in the social sciences
uh because the social sciences for
decades have really foregrounded race is
this fundamental aspect of our
psychology
um that we code Everyone by race
immediately and there's quite a bit of
evidence that people do encode you know
as soon as you see somebody that one of
the first things you're going to think
of is that a black guy or a white guy or
you know Mexican or Asian uh you're
going to code race really quick uh it's
going to influence all kinds of
decisions and behaviors
um and that's been part of you know
non-evolutionary social science forever
so
uh what evolutionary psychology
has proposed
is that we humans evolved in Africa and
if we go back to two and a half million
years ago our brains were about the size
of chimp brains about one-third of
um the human size that we have today so
400 cubic centimeters versus about 12 to
1300 cubic centimeters so it's tripling
over that two million years and that all
occurred
in Africa
and then very very very recently modern
humans with modern human size brains and
modern behaviors and modern capabilities
expanded Out of Africa and colonize the
rest of the world so all of us uh just a
few minutes ago in evolutionary time
were
big brain modern humans uh in Africa
and what we argue is that that massive
brain expansion we evolved a our unique
human cognitive abilities that are
shared by everybody today because we all
came from that same population of of
Africans um just a few tens of thousands
of years ago
so uh as you may notice here there's no
race anywhere in that conception
and the race is quote unquote
um come about because
um in that very very recent expansion of
modern humans Out of Africa of course
you're colonizing Asia and Europe and
the Americas and
um in that relatively short time frame
some very very minor physical
differences have evolved skin color
um you're actually really hard you can
put almost all of the differences on you
know a little infographic there's so few
of them
um there are a few things where there's
really strong selection pressures like
solar radiation or pathogens or diet or
if you're at high altitude oxygen levels
or things like malaria resistance but
they're very very very very very minor
in the scheme of things and what we
argue is in that very narrow sliver of
time there just wasn't time for much of
any
um
evolution of of complex psychological
differences any differences that might
exist between populations would be about
as significant as having a little bit
more versus a little bit less melanin in
your melanocytes so your skin cells
um
and so that's been the perspective of
evolutionary psychology for uh since its
Inception however there is a real
problem I don't want to diminish this we
do have
folks who've kind of latched on to the
evolutionary psychology label
um who uh are very interested in the
possibility that just as there are
physiological
population differences there might be
psychological population differences
um
and that's never been part of mainstream
evolutionary psychology but some folks
are really interested in that
um it's obviously a hugely controversial
topic um some of the evolutionary
psychology journals have accepted papers
that have been purporting to provide
evidence for that those papers have
relied on a uh National IQ database that
is extremely problematic and has really
no claim to have accurate numbers on
Nation level IQ for many many nations
getting basically a nation boiling a
whole nation down to a single number we
can do it but it's it takes you know
literally might take a million dollars
to do it right and that kind of money
was not put into this research I can
tell you that and that'd be for one
nation to get that one accurate number
for that one nation on any one number
that you wanted uh is a very very
expensive thing to do and this data set
doesn't do that at all
so yes there is a problem now that some
evolutionary psychology journals are
publishing some very
suspect papers promoting the idea that
there are population differences in
intelligence
um and that's going to take some work to
deal with that to begin to
um
counter some of those narratives with
much better research
um and much better reviewing
um I think there's quite a bit of
evidence that the quality of reviews
that are going on subpar
so we're working on that
um is it part of the what has inspired
literally hundreds of social scientists
who adopt evolutionary ideas now
um it's really not been the inspiration
the inspiration has been this kind of
vision of a the psychic Unity of mankind
that that we all have
a common repertoire of psychological
mechanisms
um that unite us
what do you say to the people that
accuse evolutionary psychology of being
Just So Stories
well
um
you could say I could say I'm a fan of
gesso's Stories the more the better uh
we always you know all science starts
off with a gesso story that we have some
we see some phenomenon nature that we
find interesting and we come up with a
story about it what explains that
phenomenon
um and so we evolutionary psychologists
are as liable to do that as everybody
else and all the other scientists and
all the other sciences and all the other
disciplines
uh but then you gotta test it and just
um as every scientist and every other
discipline does we begin to design
experiments to test these ideas and some
of them hand out and some don't
um so yeah we we love our uh Just So
Stories but we also love uh science
um and the scientific method and
Empirical research and if you look at
any
evolutionary psychologists they have a
very robust Empirical research program
to test their ideas and some of them
have been panned out and some haven't
I'll give you one that that didn't pan
out or doesn't seem to uh this debate is
still there but
um there's a lot of there were a lot of
very interesting I thought Just So
Stories that uh mating preferences might
for women might vary across the
menstrual cycle
and there were some preliminary
empirical evidence in favor of that but
much bigger uh and more controlled
Studies have really failed to find that
mating preferences change across the
menstrual cycle so that's an example of
a great theory is one that suggested
empirical tests
um it was amenable to empirical testing
those empirical tests have been done and
have not found support
for the theory and that's how science
Works um it's hard to figure out how the
world Works uh so we're going to have
many many just or just those stories
that just uh don't pan out and that we
have to be okay with that
um
that's the only way we're going to make
progress if we rule out uh telling
stories then science dies
it's such a shift that the it's such a
shame that the ovulatory shift
hypothesis didn't end up being true
because it's just so interesting it was
so much maybe it was cool you know it is
very cool but maybe there'll be some new
twists on it
um I don't know that we've heard the
last word uh but yeah right now
classes yeah it may not be dead yet uh
who knows
um
who knows uh there may be some new
twists on it
um we'll see uh but yeah for right now
uh it's not looking good
one of the other things that you've
studied is music and ancestrally
evolutionarily the role that music and
dance and other uh actions had how does
that fit into anything resembling an
evolutionary or adaptive story to for
humans
yeah so my career I thought when I first
was introduced to evolutionary
psychology I thought well if this is
right it should be able to answer
questions that nobody's been able to
answer it really make some progress on
some of the big Mysteries things like
depression and suicide
and music is one of those big Mysteries
that Darwin himself puzzled over
um it seems if we look at you know food
and mating these are all behaviors that
have clear evolutionary utility
um and you look at something like music
and it's just what is the
what could be the utility with that kind
of behavior there's it's not at all
obvious
um so if evolutionary approaches are
going to prove their worth they should
be able to begin to give us
insights and and it won't be any
surprise based on everything that I've
said that I kind of take a signaling
approach here and a credible
signaling approach because a lot of the
strange things that we see in animals
end up being signals of some sort
um
uh and often costly or uh the kinds of
signals that you can't
fake and so
um when I began thinking about
um
music and what the heck uh is going on
there I thought well what's what's
really distinctive about it and there
are of course many distinctive features
when we compare to language or other
kinds of auditory signals things that we
know are signals
uh but the thing I decided to tackle was
um The Joint performances that and
they're incredibly well
synchronized in fact the way I was
driving to work one day
um as a grad student and an old song
came on the radio that I hadn't heard
and you know since my high school days
and I was able to immediately sing along
with the song in perfect synchrony the
lyrics Just Came Back effortlessly
and if this had been a you know a verbal
account you know linguistic just a
normal I would never I wouldn't be able
to remember anything
uh and yet I can remember this thing and
not only remember but just engage with
precise synchrony and so that's what
really fascinated me that precise
synchronization is this key element of
music it's not the only thing obviously
but it's really critical to the whole
experience and I thought what could be
the the function of precise
synchronization and this musical memory
I thought you know the only way I could
remember this is if I had a specialized
psychological adaptation to Remember
music
and I've had that precise synchrony
uh could be a signal of Coalition
quality
uh that the only way that you can
achieve that precise synchrony is with a
lot of practice uh it's really hard to
learn a song and get everything
synchronized
and so when we learn music
uh we've got to practice to master our
instruments and then we practice songs
together
and so uh receivers if they it might
take and in fact when I began to look in
the ethnographic record sure enough
folks would be spending weeks and months
practicing songs and dances for an
upcoming feast
uh but they're going to give that song
they're going to present it in just a
few minutes or maybe an hour
in a very short amount of time so it
would allow Observers
to observe something that would be very
very difficult to assess otherwise how
much of these people how willing are
they to cooperate with each other how
long have they known each other
um are they a really highly coordinated
Coalition and if You observe a group of
musicians and dancers you can tell very
very quickly whether or not they have
been practicing together for a long time
or not and that would have been critical
in our evolution
because humans are quite unique in that
we cooperate not just at the individual
level but at the group level groups
cooperate with other groups so groups
really need to assess the Coalition
quality of the folks that they made Ally
with because they may depend on them for
their lives and military conflicts and
battles or if they're sharing food those
guys better be good Hunters
um so a hypothesis is that
these joint musical performances May
signal to potential allies that yeah we
are a really high quality Coalition and
you guys should Ally with us
that would explain why that's my Jackson
Remember songs from
14 15 16 years ago and yeah I
you're totally right I can't remember I
can barely remember anything from my
entire University degree but if you play
me any emo slash Pop Punk song from 2003
to 2009 I can recite it Pitch Perfect I
can tell you what the lyrics were
because I looked up the lyrics online
and then went back and updated my
programming around that word that
sounded like another word and I used to
go instead of actually saying what the
word was uh yeah I I it's very
interesting that
that we almost have this purpose-built
circuitry for it is what's the reason
that music have you considered a reason
for why music makes us feel good or why
it can create a psychological State
change within us
yeah I I don't have a any I think it
would just be the kind of obvious thing
that anything that we do that increases
our biological Fitness we're going to
probably feel good uh to encourage us to
do that thing and anything that
decreases our biological Fitness is
going to probably make us feel bad
so uh uh practicing music and you know
when I was in the Jazz Band in high
school nothing was more fun than just uh
you know playing gigs
um and having people kind of rock out or
dance to the thing it just was this
thing you know just infusion of Good
Feelings
um and the argument would be because
you're doing things that actually are
going to increase your Fitness you are
uh learning how to send a signal that
you've got a really strong Coalition and
um other folks would benefit by
cooperating with you instead of those
guys in the other Valley
so yeah it's it's in our fitness to
master these things and do well at them
and we feel good when we when we do that
Ed Hagen ladies and gentlemen if people
want to keep up to date with the stuff
that you do online where should they go
uh just Google me Google Ed Hagen and
you and you'll find me real quick on
Google you'll find my faculty page and
um also Ed Hagan on Twitter uh if you
want to see me rant uh about
evolutionary just those stories that I
love
I do I do indeed Ed I really appreciate
you thank you for today
thanks for having me on
what's happening people thank you very
much for tuning in if you enjoyed that
episode then press here for a selection
of the best clips from the podcast over
the last few weeks and don't forget to
subscribe
peace